klay Thompson three-point field rolled
klay Thompson
elbow jumper when they get 16 of the
Warriors 30 just dribbles into a three
and buries another one five in the game
already
that's my late opsin again
sex of seven
people are out like they are dream on
cycling around play topside
[Applause]
hostage
[Applause]
lay
Chicago fans
clay wanted that three holiday was aware
of it late I saw a bit rage he pulled up
and he had to squirt it up here I don't
think they'll come out until he gets 40
and I think he had
he's got 41 okay but he also has 11
threes Jim he's five of eight he's got
13 flames got another one he got his
rhythm back well he's one away from the
record fan stream on a Damien catchin
two three they're not he's taught step
Stephan curry just came over and looked
at us and said 13 yeah John pocket for I
think they're looking for him to get 15
shots there's 49 might be really
appropriate
[Applause]
let's
[Applause]
artisan three got fouled a four-point
play coming up for the spirited one
wearing the headband tonight his field
got of you are Keith Morris is checked
in Wizards turn it over and heart is by
himself and another timeout for the
Wizards absolutely helped teams out he's
a good player hard foul Martin isoing on
Keith Morris turns a corner and gets all
the way to the rack art nice swing on
wall shoots for three
[Music]
[Applause]
Jim for the final possession here for
the Rockets to close out the quarter
Martin turns a corner gets all the way
to the rack and lays it up at edge
he past won't Bellamy and Phil Cheniere
two all-time legends the Wizards
franchise layup good for Artie mcdhh
Antoni tries to find some kind a lot of
combinations that can get the job done
Horan straight line drive at Brian and
Hardinge time with a nice
[Applause]
all right steps back let's it go 34 is
33 under 90 seconds to go in the quarter
rockets up five harden ten straight
points barn outside Iran ski steps right
bingo he told Thomas at Ramstein 82
combines between a hard and boring
[Music]
one only here in overtime at the end of
regulation dismiss that one free throw
hopefully a chance for him something to
redeem himself ere is he shoots the
Korean oxidant that she won stems
towards coming back from the seven-point
deficit